What's your background, Braxton? Braxton
Dan, I'm actually I'm actually new to
the faith. I uh currently, in your
words, I I attend a uh the denomination
of non-denominational Christians. All
right. Well, that you're on a journey,
brother. You see, we didn't remember it
took me 20 years to get where I'm at
right now. But so, what's up? Yeah. I um
I So, I uh I had a question. I studied
with Jehovah's Witnesses. Well, not
really much. I was a kid when I was uh
um my last three years of high school uh
with my parents and they brought up this
uh term about shield translating they
basic they they claimed it translates to
the ground instead of hell grave. Yes.
Grave. Yeah. So they don't they don't if
I could be wrong but they said they
don't believe in like a hell in the in
the same way that Exactly. Christians do
what? Can you explain that to me? Yes.
The Jehovah's Witnesses
believe you are your soul. Your soul is
you. Your soul is not something that's
separate from your body, right? That
continues to exist when your body dies,
right?
So you are your soul. Your soul is you.
When you die, your soul is extinguished.
Your soul is what animates your body.
You are your soul. Your soul is you. And
once you die, that's it. Now they
believe once you die, you cease to
exist. You only exist in Jehovah's
memory.
Okay. So this is what they believe. Now
what do they think hell is? Hell is
not Hell is not a
place a dimension where the righteous
are sent to be tormented.
Hell is to them where God wipes you out
of existence without a possibility of
recreating you. Hell is to cease to
exist forever and ever. That's what hell
is according to Jehovah's Witnesses.
Okay. You understand the difference?
Uh well, so so and and then and then
Christians we believe is a it's a
separation from God. That's that and and
what what more specifically do
Christians believe about hell? Because
depending on what church you go to,
you're going to have a different answer.
The Catholic tradition is clear. The
Orthodox tradition is
clear. Hell is a state in which you'll
be forever severed from the love of God,
fellowship with God, communion of God,
the peace and joy of God because you
chose not to surrender to God. You chose
not to be united to God. So hell is
never
ending separation from God's love
communion fellowship where you won't
experience the joy and peace and love of
God anymore.
Right? Okay. I I hear you. It's forever
and ever and ever. This is what the
Catholic Orthodox tradition teach. In
fact, the Catholic, the Orthodox
tradition would say that in so far as
you go to hell, that's because God in
his love is giving you what you want.
What do I mean? God in his love is
giving you what you want. If you don't
want to be with God and you don't want
to dwell with God and you don't you
don't want to have anything to do with
God and I'm talking about the true God.
I'm talking about the true God. If you
don't have nothing to do with the true
God because you've made up your mind,
God can't be as he says he is. God can't
be trinity. Jesus can't be God in the
flesh. So I refuse to accept this God. I
refuse to worship this God. So I'm going
to worship another God that I think
exists when reality doesn't. So if you
don't want to be with the true God, then
God in his love respects your decision
and hands you over. But now here's the
question.
If you don't be with the true God and
he's a source of love, peace,
joy,
mercy, ecstasy, if you don't want to be
with
him, then he hands you over to what you
want. But in handing you
over, that means he's giving you your
desire of not wanting to be with him.
But if you're not with him, that means
you you cut off yourself from what? the
source of infinite love, compassion,
mercy, joy and ecstasy. Right? Yes. So
once you cut off yourself from that
source, the source of perfect infinite
love, perfect infinite joy, perfect
infinite peace, perfect infinite
compassion, you're no longer connected
to that source. Guess what you're going
to
experience? What are you going to
experience?
uh uh terror, bewilderment,
misery, misery,
depression, right? Frustration. Yeah. So
there is an understanding that hell is
actually in one sense, be careful, I
don't want you guys misquote me. In one
sense,
hell is a display and demonstration of
God's love. In this sense, God does not
force you to love him. God does not
force you against your will to submit to
him. Because if he is truly the source
of infinite
love and he is love,
love is definitional to his nature. Love
originates from him. Then to force you
to love me, that's not true love. That's
divine rape. When Right. Yeah. No, I
agree. I agree with that. Yeah. So in a
weird way, in a weird way, if you
understand the nature of love, nature of
hell, in a weird
way, those who end up in hell is because
God in his love will not force them to
love him. So he gives them what they
want
in a weird way. But in giving you what
you want, then you no longer experience
the joy, the peace, the love, the
compassion of God. You now experience
displeasure, pain, misery, right? Yeah.
Loneliness, despair.
Yeah. I So my my my question is is where
where then in the Bible was uh is a
point that uh this is a genuine question
that points to the uh uh the separation
of of of of the soul and the body. Then
because because Jehovah's Witnesses, you
said they they don't believe in that
that separation. Where does the Bible
point to that? Too many verses. You mean
the 10,000 sessions that I've done going
through all the evidence? Okay. Sorry.
You have to go here. I've done many
things on the afterlife. But the only
problem is they will have their own way
of explaining these
passages in accord with their theology.
And this is why even their own
translation, they will take specific
words and not translate them accordingly
but mistransate them. That's why they
have their own Bible version. So if you
do afterlife search engine
afterlife strobble afterlife afterlife
experiences more on the afterlife the
rich man right here rich man Lazarus
afterlife death and the afterlife life
after death how many sessions I've done
for the afterlife near-death experience
there you go just put in afterlife
near-death experiences right just put in
afterlife and watch my sessions I
shouldn't And now I now I see them. But
I um I uh so I guess and and I need to
just sit and actually read the Bible. I
mean I started in John in February. I'm
still in John. I just need to forgive
me. I just need to take more time and
actually read the Bible.